the former chairman of the Japanese car
giant Nissan has arrived in Lebanon
saying that he's escaped injustice and
political persecution in Japan
Carlos Cohen was arrested in Tokyo in
2018 of allegations of financial
misconduct which he denies he was
released from custody under strict bail
conditions including not being allowed
to leave the country in a statement go
and said that he had been trapped in a
rigged Japanese justice system and had
to escape Michael Penn is the president
of the she gets her news agency at joins
us now live via Skype from Tokyo good to
have you with asset Michael given those
strict bail conditions how was going
able to leave Japan well that's the
story that all the journalists in Tokyo
are pursuing right now and the answers
have not become clear he was as far as
we knew under house arrest including
cameras monitoring his movements inside
the house so how did he suddenly show up
in Lebanon this is something nobody
expected and nobody has been able to
explain yet this is this is a big
question how did he get out and who
helped him get out because it's
impossible to believe that he did this
all as one individual obviously he
either paid people or people from
outside came in to help him escape
he says he's escaped injustice and
political persecution in Japan and
what's likely to be the reaction to that
there well probably if the past is any
guide that the Japanese government will
just dismiss those allegations and and
try to ignore them to as much as they
can it is a view that many observers
will sympathize with because there are
deep flaws in the Japanese legal system
and the way that Goan was being handled
was very much kind of a railroad job but
on the other hand there's also a large
stream of thought that even if the
Japanese system is is deeply flawed that
say it's justice system it would have
been much better for him to stay and
fight and and suffer the punishment if
it came
because that would be better for those
who whose he's kind of left behind here
you know there will be other court cases
in the future where the police and
prosecutors won't want to let suspects
go because of what going did so what
happens to the case against him now and
will we will we ever know whether he was
guilty of what he was actually accused
of well under the Japanese legal system
once you are indicted you have a 99
percent chance of being convicted
so to its kind of too much to expect
that the truth would come out you might
say during the Japanese trial in any
case but what will happen now is a good
question we that's another thing we
don't know the answer to yet there's a
probably a large chance that it will
more or less be dropped for the time
being because the case is also an
international embarrassment for Japan so
in some sense you know it's not a bad
thing for the government here either
Michael just remind us in what sort of
state is the the company that that he
once chaired that the car giant Nissan
and these sons in trouble since he left
and actually from shortly before he left
you know its sales and financial
situation began to decline during the
year so he's been under legal trouble
things have gotten worse for the for the
company they had a president who who
tried to take control and then was taken
out and they just lost their number
three person who was supposed to be the
person handling the the turnaround so
Nissan itself is in considerable
difficulty now good to talk to you
Michael many thanks indeed Michael
Pender the president of the shigatsu
news agency in Tokyo